ces deux rien attendre ce que je cherche
c'est certainement un peu plus de
compréhension
parce qu'on est un peu dans
l'incompréhension forcément quand on
vient événement de ce type là bon là on
est bientôt à 6 ans de cette attente a
donc le temps passe mais
voilà on a besoin de comprendre un peu
plus ce qui nous est arrivé et puis on a
besoin de passer à autre chose alors on
voit ce procès comme une étape
voilà et ce procès vient donc de
s'ouvrir à paris ce mercredi à la mi
journée c'est le procès hors norme des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 bonjour
paul gonzalez vous couvrez la justice au
service société du figaro salah abdeslam
qui est l'un des principaux accusés a
parlé c'est ce qu'on a guetté c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir de cette première
journée qu'est ce qu'il a dit
précisément et bien finalement il n'a
pas dit davantage de ski est là que ce
qu'il a pu dire lors de son précédent
procès en belgique en 2018 il a commencé
par une profession de foi très classique
pour un acte de prosélytisme
avant mais voilà de répondre aux
questions du juge absolument comme il
l'avait fait d'ailleurs au moment de son
procès en belgique quasiment mot pour
mot
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
il a rappelé ensuite ultérieurement
qu'il était toujours un conte à un
combattant de l'état islamique ça c'est
quand on lui demande quels sont les noms
de votre père et de votre mère il répond
il n'est pas question de nom de votre
père je suis d'abord et avant tout un
combattant compétents de l'état island -
c'est aussi quand on lui demande de ses
fonctions ou sa profession il dit j'ai
tout abandonné pour être un combattant
de l'état islamique donc il refait en
quelque sorte allégeance à l'état
islamique et est ensuite il ya cette
question d'identité que je trouve très
intéressante de dire mon père et ma mère
n'ont rien à voir est ce que c'est une
façon de renoncer à une filiation à sa
propre filiation ou est ce au contraire
une façon de les mettre à l'écart et
finalement finalement de les protéger
vous avez vous êtes penché justement sur
la nouvelle vie de salah abdeslam en
prison en isolement total
à fleury mérogis qu'est-ce qu'il
qu'est-ce qui vous frappe dans cette
prise de parole
dans la prise de parole pendant pendant
le procès va finalement je suis pas de
trop étonné si vous voulez parce que ce
que disent les les surveillants qui
l'entourent
c'est que quand même depuis deux trois
ans il parle un peu davantage enfin
essayez quand même sorti de son mutisme
il commence à avoir une conversation
avec avec les gardiens bon pour des
choses minimes pour ses repas ses
cantines
mais c'est plus l'homme mutique qu'on a
connu quand il est arrivé en détention
au lendemain des attentats
la seconde chose c'est que bon c'est
assez peu 10 mai même même en étant en
est en isolement s'est pas complètement
étanche donc
il l'a sans doute mais changer où ils
échangent pendant pendant sa détention
avec
sans doute ses codétenus même si c'est
très très restreint et qu'il est
absolument filmé et entendu donc
finalement bon dans ce qu'il a dit là
aujourd'hui je suis pas certaine que ça
soit très cc est représentatif de ce qui
n'est mais peut-être pas de sastre âge
de sa stratégie à venir et peut demain
retomber dans le mutisme et ne plus et
ne plus parler quand bien même
il retomberait dans le mutisme combien
même il n'y retournerais pas dans sa
réponse quand même on voit quelqu'un qui
a plutôt ce qu'on appelle en stratégie
judiciaire une stratégie de rupture il
cherche pas coopérer avec le tribunal ou
à ni cherche plutôt là la rupture ou
l'affrontement avec le tribunal
absolument et d'ailleurs il n'est pas le
seul c'est que souvent dans l'est dans
les procès terroristes on peut voir
cette stratégie de la rupture on l'a vu
avec l'affairé glam on l'a vu avec la
sphère du thalys avant on l'avait vu
avec carlos qui a pratiqué la stratégie
de la rupture également ou
soit par des en soit on sent
on utilise sa stratégie en faisant des
déclarations et des incantations où on
se mure dans le silence mais de toute
façon dont les procès terreau
habituellement il ya toujours quand même
en face est rare que qui est qu'ils
aient la volonté de de collaborer comme
vous dites avec la justice je crois
qu'on est bien bien au delà de ça et
pour la bonne raison que de toute façon
quand on est hervé c'est un refus de des
institutions et quoi de plus
représentatif des institutions que la
justice quelles que soient les causes
terroristes d'ailleurs quelles que
soient les causes que les terroristes
poursuivre c'est une stratégie qui est
fréquente dans les procès terrorisme
vous êtes en train de nous dire que
recherche ceci dit salah abdeslam dans
cette dans cette éventuelle stratégie de
rupture quel est l'enjeu pour lui au
cours de ce procès alors on y pense tout
ça
salam de slam c'est le seul qui s'est
pas fait kippa martyrs qui s'est pas
fait exploser contrairement aux autres
qui est pas mort bon moi je pense qu'on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de
d'imaginer que il a il a quand même une
allégeance de plus si je puis dire
à revendiquer du fait qu'il ne soit pas
allé jusqu'au bout de ce de son acte et
c'est quand on le voit dire je suis
toujours combattants de l'état islamique
il y à un sous-texte derrière qui nous
dit ça qu'il nous dit je n'ai pas trahi
parce que finalement je ne suis pas un
lâche et je ne suis pas un lâche je ne
suis pas un lâche c'est la suspicion qui
pèse sur ce lob de tout à fait tout à
fait
pourquoi lui enfin quels sont les chefs
de mise en examen
qui pèsent à son encontre pourquoi est
il exactement poursuivi il est poursuivi
pour faits de terrorisme
voilà et au regard organisation d'actes
d'actes terroristes propre proprement
dit son rôle ça a été à la fois d'avoir
pris part à la halle après à la
préparation et à l'exécution
absolue de l'attak mais même là en tout
cas c'est sûr pourquoi il est poursuivi
tout à fait mais ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que s'il ya une zone taille
à quelques zones d'ombré dans ce procès
et je pense que le rôle exact de salles
abdeslam dans dans cet attentat
reste une zone d'ombré parce que
finalement on le retrouve là où il
n'aurait pas dû être
nuisible que j'étais en perdition je ne
suis pas au jeu je sais pas trop où
j'étais et c'est en même temps on trouve
dans sa documentation
la possibilité d'un attentat
dans le xviiie dans le métro
également il s'est rendu donc en fait 8
man et est une grande zone d'ombré du
procès des treize quels sont les autres
des enseignements de cette première
journée alors moi je trouve que ce qui
est très
très émouvant et ce qui ce qui me marque
c'est ce qu'a pu dire le président
d'audience d'entrée de jeu en évoquant
la nécessité de de mener de mener ce
procès en toute humilité
donc je trouve que c'est assez rare de
d'avoir comme ça une audience qui
commence en disant que
on va amener un pouce et en étant humble
par rapport par rapport à tout ça dans
la dignité aussi
il ya aussi l'idée d'être de leurs
appels de qu'on est dans une dans un
procès aussi historique et plus encore
je pense il ya cette idée de vouloir
rendre la justice c'est à dire de
pouvoir permettre et c'est ce que dit le
président au cours de cette première
audience de pouvoir permettre à chacun
de s'exprimer et de véritablement juger
à partir de charge à partir de faits
donc d'être dans l'exercice démocratique
de la justice
à une canne ou demande olivier rooney
n'a été officiellement désignée comme
l'avocate de salles abdeslam est ce
qu'on connaît les raisons de ce choix
alors c'est lui qui l'a choisi un
précédemment il avait retoqué ses deux
avocats et puis
il l'a découvert
olivia rhône ain dans un dans une
émission télé je crois même de m6 où
elle intervenait
rappelant qu'elle avait déjà été avocate
de jeunes radicalisé mais aussi de
deux militants
d'extrême droite
et c'est lui qui l'a contacté il ya une
polémique d'ailleurs sur ce point
paul puisque on a appris que les avocats
de la défense devront être payées par
une partie des honoraires des avocats
des parties civiles ce qui a soulevé
l'indignation de certaines d'entre elles
de ces parties civiles pourquoi pourquoi
ce choix est ce que l'om est en deux
sets la polémique elle perdurera perdura
peut-être maintenant je crois que c'est
très très clair que ça soit du côté de
la chancellerie et surtout de l'ordre et
du barreau de paris
c'est que et d'ailleurs quand quand on
évoque du président pires
à cette audience il le dit il faut un
procès équitable un procès équitable ça
veut dire qu'il doit y avoir
une défense digne de ce nom qui peut
faire son travail avec des vrais droits
de la défense des parties civiles qui
sont représentées qui s'exprime or si
vous voulez la particularité des avocats
de la défense contrairement à ceux des
parties civiles c'est que eux siègent en
permanence on y vont siéger pendant neuf
mois tous les jours enfin quatre jours
par par semaine à ce procès que ça va
leur prendre un temps infini et qu'ils
sont payés sur l'aide juridictionnelle
autrement dit
si les temps et que les avocats des
parties civiles sont pas forcément
toujours là alors voilà c'est ça c'est
ça donc il fait son parti 6800 parties
civiles vous êtes là quand vous devez
premières paroles mais dont vous pouvez
continuer à avoir un cabinet à côté puis
à faire votre travail vous n'en mourrez
pas côté défense
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué parce que
vous êtes immobilisé pendant neuf mois
avec un seul client donc je crois que
d'abord il ya deux shows à l'orias ça en
sachant que tout ce procès financés par
l'aide juridictionnelle par l'état et
c'est vrai qu'au départ
la chancellerie ne souhaitait pas
totalement
entièrement financé les avocats de la
défense et comme le barreau de paris
souhaitait qu'on soit dans un procès
absolument équitable tout le monde
puisse exercer ses droits et bien et
c'est prévu dans le règlement du barreau
de paris en phase est prévue par la loi
et c'est prévu par une annexe du
règlement cette annexe 9 la possibilité
pour que ces droit s'exerce que une
partie des airs de la rémunération de la
partie adverse permettent de financer
l'autre partie et c'est ce qui se passe
alors entre temps la chancellerie a
accepté d'augmenter cette aide
juridictionnelle
ce qui fait que les avocats des parties
civiles vont contribuer moins lourdement
5 % au lieu de 10% mais donc c'est
l'idée vous voyez du procès équitable et
que les droits de la défense puisse
exercer une pratique qui est prévu par
la loi c'est une pratique qui prévues
par le barreau de paris est ce que c'est
une pratique qui est fréquente
non parce que on a rarement été dans
cette danse est problématique d'un
procès qui dure aussi longtemps neuf
mois qui
qui est calculé en fonction de demi
journées mais on sait que les avocats
vont être là dès le matin pour voir
leurs clients donc en fait ils sont
présents dès le matin donc ils sont
payés sur une demi-journée par l'aide
juridictionnelle mais en fait beaucoup
plus voilà c'est un procès hors norme
c'est un financement hors norme
également de l'art de la défense alors
permis
le trade caractéristiques qui font que
ce procès est hors norme c'est sa
longueur pourquoi le procès et si l'on
alors déjà parce que vous avez
énormément de partie civile vous avez
vous avez 1800 parties civiles
inscrits aujourd'hui avec la possibilité
qui on est
800 700 et 800 de plus s'inscrivant en
cours de procès je pense que c'est un
procès extrêmement complexe parce que on
a on n'a pas une unité de lieu dans ces
attentats plusieurs attentats en fait
dans un même procès en quelque sorte il
ya le stade de france égalité raciale
bataclan donc c'est une procédure qui
est extrêmement qui est extrêmement
longue dans tout ça fait 1 million pages
ça fait 5 140 hommes cc c'est le plus
gros appareil
que l'on puisse avoir donc cette cette
multiplicité des attentats
en quelque sorte cette multiplicité des
parties civiles des blessés c'est
l'attentât qui a fait le plus de
victimes aussi nécessite un temps
extrêmement quelles vont être les
moments clés et les moments forts alors
les moments clés vont intervenir fin
vote déjà la fin septembre quand on va
avoir les premiers témoignages de
victimes mais vous voyez ça vient
extrêmement tard donc je vois pas ce
qu'on va faire beaucoup de procédures
auparavant la plante là toute la partie
qui commence maintenant jusqu'à fin
septembre ses de la procédure c'est
quasiment c'est une voix lasse
essentiellement c'est essentiellement de
la procédure on va commencer à
s'intéresser à la personnalité des
accusés qu'à la mi novembre
donc vous voyez que ça prend ça prend du
temps
donc là ça sera aussi un temps fort en
même temps qu'il y aura cette
présentation des accusés il y aura aussi
des témoignages de leurs familles donc
je pense que ça ça va être aussi un
moment clé et puis après on va aussi
avoir les témoignages de deux policiers
d'hommes politiques puisque françois
hollande va intervenir l'ancien ministre
l'intérieur également
voilà c'est lors ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que ces moments forts vont
être sont dispatchés ne vont pas se
concentrer sur une partie du procès mais
ça va aller et venir puisque la volonté
du président pires quand il a organisé
cette audience et de faire des
allers-retours justement entre les les
moments
la chronologie si vous voulez deux de
ces attentats qu'est-ce que vous
personnellement qu'ils avaient penché
sur ces procès sur leur préparation vous
raconter aux lecteurs du figaro qu est
ce que vous vous allez gaieté
moi je pense que ce qui va être malgré
tout intéressant quoique quoi qu'on en
dise c'est enfin je crois qu'il ya deux
choses c'est d'abord de découvrir
comment on fait fonctionner le hic dèche
comment comment prouver progressivement
au fil des années ils se sont
professionnalisés comment ils ont essayé
beaucoup de choses avant d'arriver à cet
attentat terrifiant ce qu'ils ont raté
ce qui est ensuite comment ils ont
réagit donc voir en gros commencé ces
gens là se sont pressées
professionnaliser je crois que c'est
très important je reste quand même
curieuse moi personnellement de de la
trajectoire des des accusés je crois que
ça quand on s'intéresse un peu à cette
question ça reste toujours mystérieuse
ce ce passage à l'acte est et comment on
va jusque
dans cet engagement jusqu'au boutiste
quand même voir que ces gens avant de
d'arriver en france pour commettre leurs
exactions
ont fait
ont prêté allégeance ont expliqué ce
qu'ils allaient faire et pour
accompagner ces déclarations ont quand
même commis face caméra des exactions
épouvantable eh bien on va suivre ça
avec vous merci beaucoup paul gonzalez
peut-être une toute dernière réponse
avec une question et une réponse rapide
pourquoi n'y at il pas de jury populaire
lors de ce procès
alors bon le terrorisme c'est
c'est très spécifique
on a peur d'une émotion particulière et
donc on est on voudrait entre guillemets
rationaliser en ne mettant que des
magistrats professionnels quelque chose
comme ça quelque chose comme ça et là on
nous demande qui paye la défense de
salles abdeslam et bien on a répondu
avec une partie de l'aide
juridictionnelle et une autre partie
selon la demande du l'ordre du barreau
de paris et bien une partie des
honoraires des avocats des parties
civiles merci beaucoup paul gonzalez vos
articles et bien sûr sont à retrouver
dans le chat et sur le site du figaro le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre est
à suivre minute par minute dans le live
texte du figaro avec les comptes rendus
de nos envoyés spéciaux ils pouvaient
retrouver aussi le live vidéo qui dans
lequel nous avons fait vivre l'ouverture
du procès en milieu de journée